new year new you thinking of mixing
plant-based keto or intermittent fasting
into your diet our next guest has the
answers she is the weight loss expert
Tana Ashley over a million Instagram
followers want your advice and we're so
happy to have you with us today thank
you thank you I'm happy to be here Tana
so many people are trying to find a new
way of eating a new way to change your
lifestyle and there's some different
options that you have yes what do you
what do you see people really
gravitating towards so a lot of people
will jump to stuff like plant-based keto
and intermittent fasting those are like
the easiest ones to really just jump on
board with let's talk a little bit about
plant-based first of all how do you get
all the nutrients that you need through
a plant-based diet so I mean a lot of
the plant-based diet people that I coach
we make sure that we get enough veggies
legumes lentils all of that good stuff
adding in some super greens powders as
well as vegetable broth is very very
helpful now what is the we know that
plant-bases you know all plants but then
you go over to keto and it seems like
it's almost the polar opposite of it
tell us a little bit about keto so keto
you really want to focus on getting your
proteins High fats
um so that's where I made a nice little
ground turkey some bell pepper onion
with some avocado dump some cheese sour
cream on there
and then you could also do the bone
broth which also helps with just healing
the gut and a lot of people turn to
intermittent fasting that is something
I've I've done that and I really feel
like that is for me a great way to eat
because it gives you a window can you
explain intermittent fasting so
intermittent fasting is what I tell
every single person to start with if you
don't want to switch up your eating
habits intermittent fasting is a great
way to start out so let's just say
you're someone that eats breakfast at
8am just push your window back to about
8 30 and see how you do and then as you
start mastering that go ahead and push
it back to nine and then make sure that
you stop eating by like six or seven at
night it's uh interesting because
there's different varieties of
intermittent fasting too I usually like
my window will be 11 A.M until like 6
p.m but um that's a great way to start
and you don't necessarily have to change
up your diet too much no and that's why
I tell people it's a really great way if
you're super super busy and you're like
I don't have time to understand all
these different eating Styles just start
with intermittent fasting now if you are
doing intermittent fasting is there a
way that you suggest someone just coming
into it to get started like apps just so
they know what their windows are I mean
I usually will tell my clients just to
start with simply setting an alarm on
your phone and that's the easiest way
but there are apps out there that
support it I haven't used any so I don't
know which ones why would you an alarm
seems like a perfect option super simple
if people want more information maybe
they would like to come to you for
coaching how do they get in touch with
you so Instagram is my go-to it's Tana
Ashley and that's three E's instead of
eat y at the end Tana Ashley like I said
over a million followers great great
tips and tricks thank you so much for
joining us